henri guaino conseiller spécial de
nicolas sarkozy est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous la campagne conforme à
l'elysée où le président n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat mais
quand même rigolo c'est tout comme
puisque air en gala merkel lui a apporté
officiellement son soutien sur tous les
plans at elle dit où il n'a pas pas de
campagne présidentielle non on n'a pas
parlé de campagne présidentielle mais
enfin bon le message n'était même pas
subliminal quand même c'est maintenant
de reuver l'écran mais ça c'est votre
mauvais esprits qui parle et dont il y
avait un sommet enfin un conseil des
ministres franco-allemand inat de près
chaque année par le traité de l'élysée
après une émission commune combien vu
une émission commune entre barack obama
et le président arrive à gland donc le
sommet de cannes pour évacuer peut-être
le sujet alors je serai ce qui va nous
rester vous détient aucun mélange des
genres entre un conseil des ministres
franco-allemand et puis une
présidentielle française non le fond du
trou ministre conseil des ministres en
colmant il est prévu de longue date y en
a deux par an nous ça n'a rien à voir
avec la campagne des présidentielles
alors une campagne encore française bien
sûr je sais très bien je vous repose la
première question sur le sujet dans un
instant je vous précise quand même que
philippe alfroid de l' agence
france-presse et puis perrine tarneaud
de public sénat nous rejoindrons tour à
tour mais donc d'abord régler au comment
est ce que vous le souverainiste que
vous ne mangez le raisonner mais pas ce
mot là comment dijon le pasteur moi fut
attaché à la souveraineté nationale dont
vous qui êtes attachés à la souveraineté
nationale comment est-ce que vous
réagissez quand vous entendez merkel
vote sarkozy
j'avais pas compris que madame merkel
votaient en france
elle apporte son soutien je le rappelle
au président de la république et donc
c'est une façon d'ailleurs espéré à à
l'elysée d'obtenir des soutiens
outre-rhin ça vous ne pouvez pas le nier
henri guaino a nommé pour que la
politique française soit efficace en
europe nous sommes toujours contents
d'avoir le soutien de nos amis allemands
ça
je pense que quel que soit le
gouvernement français il a besoin pour
faire avancer l'europe du soutien de
membres alors vous donc vous ne
succombez pas vous l'avais dit à l'ats
germaneau magna mais pourtant on a
l'impression
qu'elle lisait le modèle aujourd'hui
imitée c'est le modèle allemand est ce
que nous sommes trompés vous vous êtes
trompés y a pas de modèle à imiter il ya
des leçons à tirer des expériences des
autres n'y a pas de modèle à imiter le
posant de la l'a dit d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises ça n'aurait aucun
sens n'allons pas les allemands ne vont
pas devenir français et les français et
allemand c'est chacun doit essayer de
tirer le meilleur parti de lui-même de
ses ressources de sa culture de ses
traditions et puis rien en revanche ne
nous empêche de regarder les expériences
des autres et d'en tirer des leçons pour
nous a par exemple la principale leçon à
tirer porterait sûrement beaucoup de
choses je repense au dialogue social en
allemagne je pense puisque on en a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps de
l'expérience du transfert de charges
sociales sur la tva je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de leçons à tirer en matière de
compétitivité de
d'efficacité industrielle
des choses à éviter est ce que
l'allemagne aussi dans certains domaines
répondez moi franchement un régal doit
être un contre modèle ah oui par exemple
démographique je pense que l'allemagne a
des leçons à tirer la chancelière l'a
dit elle l'a dit elle même d'ailleurs de
la politique familiale française
je pense que si nous avons pouvant en
juillet
beaucoup de
qualités à l'industrie allemande je
pense que l'allemagne peut nous envier
notre dynamisme démographique par
exemple d'accord donc là la france pour
être un modèle familial est ce qu'elle
peut être un modèle social également
pour l'allemagne où la précarité après
les fameuses réformes schröder
considérablement progressé dans le pays
oui je pense qu'on va aussi de ne pas
importer la précarité pas plus que ne va
l'emporter notre taux de chômage et je
crois que la précarité elle existe aussi
existe aussi en france elle se
manifeste d'une autre d'une autre façon
et je crois que nous devons les uns et
les autres petit à petit essayer de la
réduire au maximum
aujourd'hui on le voit et on le voit
notamment avec les chiffres du commerce
extérieur la la france enregistre un
déficit record l'an dernier quelque 70
milliards d'euros on voit que
l'allemagne nous dominent
considérablement sur le sur le plan
économique et certains observateurs
disque du fait de ce fait là nicolas
sarkozy est moins l'allier que le vassal
d'angela merkel aux lisières et chaude
caricature de plus en quoi la france
telles vassaliser par l'allemagne la
france à sa politique ses principes ses
objectifs elle c'est comme l'allemagne
le sait aussi que pour faire avancer les
choses en europe il faut que chacun
fasse des compromis et que chaque fois
qu'on trouve une ligne commune entre la
france et l'allemagne alors on a une
chance de faire prévaloir nos idées en
euros frais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
leadership en europe il est assumé pour
l'essentiel par le couple franco
allemand ici ça n'était pas le cas il
n'y aurait plus de leadership du tout un
personne ne pourrait personne ne peut
espérer tout seul
pendant main les destinées de l'europe
la france et d'allemagne aujourd'hui mon
point de leurs responsabilités donc pu
pour essayer de faire avancer l'union
européenne de lui faire traverser la
période difficile qu'elle connaît
aujourd'hui et cela existe pour discuter
que l'on se mette d'accord il faut que
chacun fasse des pas vers l'autre ça
s'appelle la convergence la convergence
des points de vue et la convergence des
expériences est ce que vous êtes nitoo
franchement c'est ce que vous êtes
hérité par cet affichage du soutien dans
gala merkel et nicolas sarkozy n'a pas
d'affichage ont redouté que l'opinion
publique soit irrité elle c'est le vois
comme cela moi je crois que le problème
des élections présidentielles françaises
c'est la sphère des français voilà que
madame merkel
disent à quel point ses relations avec
le président sarkozy son bonne
constructive et fructueuse ça je n'y
vois que des avantages
maintenant la présidentielle française
c'est la sphère des français comme les
élections en allemagne c'est la sphère d
alors mais encore une question peut-être
que angela merkel soutient aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy bon ce sont des partis
amis que comme elle l'a dit bien sûr
mais parce qu'il a peur finalement de
françois hollande qui qui lui promet
sinon de renégocier du mois de compléter
le pacte but qu'est ce que ça peut être
une lecture
à je suis pas sûr que nos amis allemands
soient absolument enthousiastes à l'idée
que la france dénonce unilatéralement
dans quelques mois l'accord qui a été si
difficilement conclu entre 26 pays de
l'union européenne il y a quelques
semaines je pense d'ailleurs d'une
manière générale que cette façon de
procéder n'est pas n'est pas bonne c'est
pas plus que d'aller expliquer qu'on va
aller au prochain sommet de l'otan pour
dire à nos partenaires que
nous retirons du jour au lendemain
d'afghanistan les laissant tomber voilà
je compte le respect de nos alliés le
respect de nos partenaires et le respect
de la parole de la france est quelque
chose qui devrait imposer à tous les
hommes d'état mais vous henri guaino qui
avait toujours combattu dans vos
engagements depuis des années les
politiques sacrificielles vous ne
trouvez pas que l'europe manque d'allant
en matière de croissance en matière
d'emploi c'est ce que réclame
aujourd'hui candidat socialiste
qu'il y ait un effort allant non pas en
matière de croissance
qui associe d'agir qui n'a jamais
été abandonnée par le président de la
république la france prendre des
décisions prendre des mesures pour
essayer de relancer la croissance
observe d'ailleurs que chaque fois qu'on
en a prise depuis le début du
quinquennat on n'a jamais été soutenus
par l'opposition on sait qu'il faut de
la croissance mais l'opposition a voté
monsieur hollande en particulier contre
le grand emprunt elle dénonce toutes les
mesures que le gouvernement prend pour
essayer de doper la croissance donc
monsieur hollande le plus mal placé pour
donner des leçons dans ce domaine
mais c'est une préoccupation tout à fait
essentiel problème c'est d'entraîner nos
partenaires sur cette voie et pour
l'instant nous avons
sommes arrivés à un accord sur les
disciplines budgétaires étaient
absolument nécessaires je rappelle aussi
que dans cet accord on a fait la moitié
du chemin non mais il faut ça c'était
absolument nécessaire pour éviter que
tout s'effondre donc si on n'avait pas
fait aussi on dénonce demain ou s'ils
ont tout simplement on évoque la
possibilité de dénoncer cet accord on
prend un risque considérable avec
l'avenir de l'euro il faut le savoir
mais ça ne favoriserait pas la
croissance au contraire l'explosion de
l'eau serait une catastrophe pour la
croissance et une catastrophe économique
et une catastrophe sociale pour les
français
mais il est prévu aussi dans cet accord
que le gouvernement économique européen
le gouvernement de la zone euro va
traiter de sujets relatifs à la
croissance et aux réformes en
particulier structurelles nécessaires
pour améliorer la croissance s'est
d'ores et déjà prévu et c'est
intéressant c'est prévu à la demande
expresse de l'allemagne
donc la france qui prouve aussi que la
france fait prévaloir de temps en temps
ses points de vue puisque la france
voulait un gouvernement économique de la
zone euro dollar auquel l'allemagne
s'est longtemps opposé l'allemagne a
fini par se rallier à cette idée qui
était une idée de bon sens est la même à
son tour enrichi leu la proposition en
prévoyant que ce gouvernement économique
de la zone euro se réunir et pas
seulement pour examiner pour étudier la
discipline budgétaire mais aussi pour
étudier toutes les réformes sociales
nécessaires pour doper la croissance
alors donc voilà en tous les cas vous
attaquez françois hollande j'ai noté
assez durement reggane où vous mettez
même en cause bah oui ce son
républicanisme un oui vous avez dit que
ce n'est pas un vrai républicain jeudi
où il avait dit je vois pas en quoi
c'est dur parce que c'est une accusation
grave hein pas du tout ce point de vue
il sera c'est un vrai débat un vrai
débat j'ai dit très exactement que
monsieur hollande était assurément un
démocrate parfaitement la réponse y ait
pas républicain c'est la démocratie
c'est un régime politique
m politique la république c'est un
système de valeurs bon j'observe que
monsieur hollande depuis très longtemps
et le porte parole d'une gauche qui
n'est pas républicaine c'est à dire
qu'il n'a pas qui a passé son temps
essayé de miner le modèle républicain
mais oui mais oui que voulez vous quand
quand vous soutenez les pédagogistes
post soixante huitards qui pendant 40
ans ont ruiné l'autorité du maître à
l'école ont préféré mettre l'enfant au
centre d'école à la place du savoir et
bien vous n'êtes pas franchement
républicain voilà donc si si monsieur
hollande a changé d'avis moi je suis
tout prêt à lui faire à lui en faire
crédit à ce moment-là il dit voilà nous
nous sommes trompés nous une partie de
la gauche et nous as républicains à
monsieur chevènement mais monsieur
mélenchon puis une gauche qui n'est -
6/10 nous nous sommes trompés et
désormais nous allons faire autre chose
alors je lui offrais crédit mais
j'observe que en même temps qu'il vous
proclame son attachement à la république
non seulement il ne rompt pas avec les
pédagogistes et tous ceux qui ont qui
ont mis à bas les principes de l'école
républicaine
non mais c'est on a peu entendu il y a
on sait que c'est une clientèle très
importante de la gauche qu'une car
monsieur monsieur hollande donc s'il
veut rompre avec cette clientèle est
avec ses dérives il faut qu'ils lisent
tout simplement mais il ya bien d'autres
sujets quand il dit je veux supprimer la
cour de justice de la république qui
donne un coup de plus aux institutions
de la république quand il dit qu'il veut
ratifié la charte des langues régionales
et minoritaires il donne un coup de
boutoir terrible si dans le modèle
républicain parce que c'est reconnaître
des droits des minorités et le droit
linguistique et it est un droit tout à
fait crucial à fait crucial en ami on a
mis ici avec la faire l'unité de notre
pays à faire son unité politique et
linguistique et la norme explique que
les minorités comme si la république
pouvait reconnaître des minorités vont
avoir des droits lundi alors voilà le
débat sur le seul un sur les vertus
républicaines oui cependant réalisme sur
l'école sur la justice qui est régulée
une sorte de république un mystique j'en
suis à nouveau interrogé sur sur claude
guéant qui a donc lancé la polémique à
partir de sa phrase sur les
civilisations qui ne se valent pas
toutes à l'assemblée nationale ce mardi
le gouvernement a quitté les bancs de
l'assemblée car un député socialiste
fait référence au nazisme
comment reste que vous réagissez à cela
je trouve ça août qu'est ce que vous
trouvez en te de faire référence au
nazisme c'est honteux voilà c'est s'est
tant qu'on aura des débats politiques de
sur ce registre là c'est celui de
l'hystérie celui du celui de la
caricature là c'est franchement c'est
même par hystérique c'est débile c'est
débile jeudi à ccc comment peut-on être
aussi bête comment savez ça me rappelle
les imbéciles qui en 1968 crir crs ss
sans doute n'avait-il jamais vu de près
un ss sans doute n'avait-il jamais
essayé de comprendre ce que pouvait être
un ss où il y en avait d'autres il y
avait aussi ceux qui défilent en 58
quand de gaulle est revenu au pouvoir
dans le fascisme ne passera pas milla le
nazisme mais qu'est ce que le nazisme
vient faire dans ces personnes qu'on
aimerait peut être les ivy lisation par
exemple la civilisation occidentale
européenne et la donner naissance au
casif à bastia c'est tout à fait vrai et
au communisme sinon voilà on peut par
effectivement associations d'idées
évoqué le nazisme dans ce débat sur les
civilisations est excessivement il
devient
le nazisme vient faire là dedans
wiki aider dans la civilisation
occidentale des dérives des crimes
terribles c'est vrai mais qu'est ce que
le nazisme ne vient faire dans ce débat
la barbarie peut être associé à toutes
ces petites ou de civilisation nous en
sommes d'accord faut-il faut-il pour
autant se
défaire se départir de la faculté de
juger je considère pas que le nazi soit
intrinsèque à la civilisation
occidentale je pense que c'en est une
pathologie terrifiante et il ya dans
d'autres civilisations des pathologies
des civilisations qui ont des comptes
est extraordinaire et des côtés sombres
je veux avoir la faculté de juger et
vous auriez pu signer vos la phrase noms
de claudio non parce que moi je passe
que parce que nos jeunes non je pense
que c'est parce que je pense que c'est
un raccourci dont il est absolu aussi
extraordinairement difficile de discuter
et de débattre dans le débat politique
n'ont pas rivalisé dans une erreur de le
dire non c'est écoutez je ne voyais pas
de géant mais
non non pas du tout c'est ce qui me gêne
c'est le style de l'interrogatoire
pardon c'est à dire que je n'ai pas à
vous dire si ça me gêne si je n'aurais
pas dit je vous n'auriez pas dit quand
même ça une information henri guaino non
mais non mais c'est cette extraordinaire
il a dit cela la question première
question première première question est
ce que le débat qui s'en est suivie est
acceptable non l'hystérie est
insupportable voilà c'est son l'hystérie
ce sont des débats très sérieux sur les
civilisations ça mérite des discussions
apaisées jeu pourquoi je pense que il
faut pas aborder ce genre de sujet dans
ce contexte là tout simplement parce que
ça n'a pas sa place dans un camp
présidentiel où les où la tension du
débat est très forte et on peut pas
discuter de sujets de ce genre voilà
parce que tant les mots sont piégés donc
lumineux
n'aurait pas dû donc non je ne vous
donne pas de noms mais cessons c'est son
problème mais absolument s'avoue peut
vous faire ricaner sais je veux dire que
vous il ya plein de choses que chacun a
envie de dire qu'il dit c'est il a dit
qu'il assumait parfaitement ce qu'il
avait dit on peut en discuter on peut
dire mission pouvait en débattre
tranquillement et sereinement moi je ne
veux pas débattre de ce supérieur de sur
un plateau de thé trois minutes au coeur
d'une campagne présidentielle voilà
simplement je vais vous dire ceci pour
finir quand même sauce sur ce sujet vous
savez toutes les civilisations sont
production une création du génie humain
et en ce sens elle mérite tout un droit
à l'existence à la compréhension et au
respect mais
tous les hommes naissent libres et égaux
en dignité et en droits ça ne m'empêche
pas d'avoir le droit de juger de leurs
qualités humaines et morales parce que
sinon si je n'en ai pas le droit ça veut
dire que il clair l abbé pierre c'est
pareil mais non c'est pas pareil voilà
non mais c'est le rallye donc la faculté
de jugement existe malgré ma conception
très profondément ancré en moi de là de
l'universalité de la dignité de la
condition donc il ya eu une universalité
de la dignité des des civilisations et
il y a ma capacité à juger sur
moralement humainement des qualités des
unes et des autres voilà et on peut
discuter de ça tout à fait sereinement
sans s'en rapprocher sa du nazisme du
racisme etc je pense qu'il faut éviter
les excès très bien voilà saint clair
sur ce sujet on va voir d'ailleurs ce
que peut dévoiler les propos de claude
guéant sur la campagne à venir de
nicolas sarkozy sur certains thèmes où
il est choqué qui pourrait servir de
trame à cette campagne on va le voir
dans un instant avec philippe alfroid de
l' agence france-presse qui va nous
rejoindre mais d'abord je vous propose
de nous suivre
sur un marché parisien du 19e
arrondissement avec des militants de
l'ump qui essayent d'inventer d'abord le
bilan de nicolas sarkozy vous vous dites
ne pas sentir d'hostilité lorsque vous
vous déplacez lors de vos propres
meetings en province on voir chrismaëlle
a posé la question mais je vous avais
harry pour ça mais j'ai vu j'ai vu je
vous ai suivi aussi un peu à distance
suivez ce reportage de bérangère dingue
là avant de poursuivre les interviews
donc avec philippe alfroid
bonjour monsieur vous l'a vu cette vidéo
de nicolas sarkozy 50 actions
au chaud autour d'un café nicolas
sarkozy n'est pas encore candidat mais
sur le terrain des petites mains
travaillent déjà pour lui on ce samedi
matin il fait moins 7 à paris et ils
sont pourtant une douzaine à tracter
parmi eux jean jacques gianesini élus du
19e arrondissement
malgré les sondages qui ne cesse de
donner nicolas sarkozy battu il y croit
et c'est vrai que nicolas sarkozy c'est
quelqu'un qui donne la pêche calvillo
qui donnait l'envié de se battre et ce
matin en cette ère du 19e acquise à la
gauche pour l'élu et accueil est plutôt
bon et vous verrez tout ce qu'il a fait
c'est bien expliqué à bien sûr qu'il a
fait on veut bien certains disent qu'il
a rien fait mais en fait il a fait
beaucoup investi
pour gérer
un changement ouais on est même bien
accueilli plus tôt alors temps en temps
vous en avait un qui nous insultent
vaudry comme ça mais mais c'est très
rare
de l'autre côté de la rue autre
technique si tina en donnant ses tracts
cite le nom du président et là ça passe
un peu moins bien au journal as
je sais pour qui je vais voter
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont mécontents ça va être très dur on
sait que la bataille des jo d'où
l'importance de faire remonter
absolument
les difficultés sur le terrain sur le
terrain les militants socialistes
étaient peu nombreux ce matin ceux de
l'ump en revanche ne sont pas prêts à
abandonner le combat ils espèrent tous
un sursaut des électeurs le jour où le
président sera officiellement candidat
donné monsieur g
bonne journée merci merci c'est gentil
avec nous
henri guaino répond à vos questions
alors on vient de le voir dans le sujet
et ça s'est reflété aussi dans les
sondages le président un problème de
popularité on va dire et donc on a
l'impression depuis quelques semaines
qu'ils axent plutôt son effort sur son
image sur sa crédibilité sur son
authenticité comme il dit est ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne méthode
pour gagner l'élection
je sais pas si c'est une bonne méthode
pour gagner les élections mais ça me
paraît une réaction légitime et normal
il explique ce qu'il a fait il montre
qu'il est comment ce qu'elle et son
rapport à la fonction tout ça me paraît
tout à fait tout à fait naturel je pense
pas qu'il y ait de savez le il n'y a pas
beaucoup de communication donc tout ça
il ya il ya simplement la volonté l'envi
d'être soi-même faso face au français au
jugement de ses concitoyens on a vu dans
le reportage aussi des beaucoup question
de bilan alors normalement moi j'aime
pas le mobile vous n'aimez pas le dos
aux bilans alors qu'est ce que j'aime
pas le mobile a vu référé bilan ça
résulte d'un arrêté des comptes alors
vous remarquerez qu'il n'ya pas d'arrêté
des comptes en politique y en a jamais
l'histoire continue hélas elles
continuent d'autant plus que la crise
qui a été le fil directeur ou la trame
de l'histoire politique depuis depuis
maintenant plus de quatre ans
elle n'est pas terminée donc l'histoire
continue la question c'est de savoir
quelle histoire dans quelle histoire il
s'est inscrit depuis le début de son
mandat et comment il compte la continuer
à lire il il n'en reste pas moins qu'il
a quand même réalisé un saison de
réforme pendant cinq ans et qu'il va
être jugé aussi sur ses réformes donc
l'idée de bilan pour un président
sortant on n'y échappe pas et encore une
fois je ne pensais pas un bilan puisque
rien de ça les compteurs ne s'arrêtent
pas les les mesures qui ont été prises
elles continuent à avoir des effets elle
en appelle d'autres et les événements
continuent nisoor continue d'avancer les
événements continuent de se produire à
coeur de mettre en avant certaines des
réformes du carnet sera la même chose
mais si c'est non c'est pas un bilan ça
c'est voit quelques l histoire il a
écrit avec les français depuis le début
de son quinquennat dans les
circonstances où nous nous trouvons mais
cette histoire ne s'attendent pas à un
moment dire j'arrête l'histoire et puis
je me retourne derrière et je fais le
compte non vous pouvez pas on va poser
la question trouvait d'ailleurs les
mesures qui ont été prises vont produire
des effets commencent en produisant
produiront demain elles en produisent
d'autant plus ou d'autant moins que les
circonstances s'y prêtent la crise par
exemple a fait que beaucoup de mesures
on ne peut pas voir l'effet d'un certain
nombre de deux mesures des mesures de
politique industrielle le président on a
pris beaucoup mais c'est vrai que ça la
claque la crise a continué de ravager le
tissu industriel donc on voit pas les
effets immédiatement donc vous pouvez
pas à un moment vous arrêter comme si
l'histoire était terminée il ya bien un
moment où les électeurs doivent se
prononcer sur un bilan non les électeurs
ont soutenu qu'ils soient ans rarement
sur un bilan de l'état il se prononce
sur l'avenir c'est à dire et bien sûr
ils prennent en compte ce qui a été fait
mais mais pour se projeter dans l'avenir
c'est pas ils vont pas non pas donner
une note sur ce seul sur sur un bilan
ils vont juger il savait qu'on avait il
analysé du président à se projeter dans
la navy dans le reportage des militants
de l'ump qui distribue une brochure sur
le bilan un volet oui mais je n'aime pas
ce mot voilà c'est être majeur jeu alors
sur les réformes curité cette devise est
pas bon maïs qui donne un état d'esprit
statique et rétrospectif que je n'aime
pas une élection ça se joue sur l'avenir
ce qui veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
parler de ce qui a été fait et de la
manière dont ce qui a été fait en
engagent l'avenir alors sur ce qui a été
c'est justement le président lui-même se
plaint régulièrement semble-t-il devant
ses ministres qu'on ne défendent pas
assez ses réformes selon vous quels sont
les 2/3 grande réforme emblématique de
son quinquennat sur lesquels il faudrait
me mettre l'accent dans mes gars n'a
bouclé en a beaucoup c'est encore une
fois c'est pas comme ça qu'on s'en sont
plaints des élections présidentielles
mais défense qui a été fait c'est la
moindre des choses il ya
l'autonomie des universités il ya le
grand emprunt
il y a le renouveau du dialogue social
de loi sur la représentativité par
exemple donc qu'ils sont quelque chose
d'extrêmement d'extrêmement important il
ya la réforme des retraites il ya le rsa
je crois que voilà on peut il ya la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites la réforme des régimes spéciaux
le service minimum enfin je pense qu'on
a jamais eu une telle densité de
réformes depuis le début de la vème
république et rire depuis les premières
années de la cinquième en 58 59 où on a
on construit à l'époque l'état toutes
les institutions
tous les instruments de la politique
économique alors le président le
président a dit récemment je crois que
c'était sûr sur
ses réformes de les replacer dans un
projet une fois comment ils engagent
l'avenir
le président a dit que les français ne
croyait plus aux promesses il a même dit
je cite à tout ce cirque est-ce que
c'est pas un peu se tirer une balle dans
le pied avant une élection
présidentielle de dire
on ne peut plus faire de promesses
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour
disait jadis ses promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les reçoivent c'est ce sont
ce que les français attendent ce sont
c'est un engagement au service donne à
leurs services au service du pays pas
une série de promesses je vous promets
geoffrey ceci ou cela mais ce qui manque
c'est un engagement son avenir ouvert où
je veux amener où je veux amener les
français sûr que cela le fondement de
quelles valeurs de quels critères de
quelle vision de l'avenir je veux demain
gouverner alors le président m'a vite et
qu'il qu'il avait en réserve un certain
nombre de propositions choc qu'elle
peuvent-elles être sûr sur quel thème
pensez vous qu'il faille lancé cette
semaine il y en a beaucoup dont qu'on
récolte par exemple l'école en état oui
on a beaucoup parlé il ya beaucoup de
choses ont été faites pour
l'enseignement je pense en particulier
l'enseignement supérieur beaucoup de
réformes ont été faites dans
l'enseignement primaire je pense qu'il
ya un effort considérable sur l'école
sur le projet éducatif
c'est ce n'est vraiment
sur la wii mais que tout ça va avec soit
pas d'enseignant à l'école et au collège
et au lycée donc là on a organes
max de proposition et d'engagement très
très important pour l'avenir c'est
penser que le président mais les autres
doivent revenir sur la question des
banlieues qui n'est évoquée par personne
ni très peu à gauche très peu à droite
et ce qui a pas là le président avait
promis un plan banlieue un plan marshall
sur les banlieues skis a pas là un
constat d'échec et un stand de livres
qui sont sortis récemment qu'ils sont
assez inquiétant sur la situation dans
la situation est inquiétante beaucoup de
choses ont été faites pendant le
quinquennat a continué assez massivement
le plan de rénovation urbaine a fait les
internats d'excellence
il ya eu beaucoup de beaucoup de moyens
beaucoup de moyens mis pour résoudre le
problème des banlieues mais on voit bien
comme pour les autres d'ailleurs secteur
delà de la politique
il faut une approche globale la question
des banlieues n'est pas n'est pas une
question simplement de quartier c'est
une question qui relève qui nous envoie
à l'école qui nous renvoie à l'emploi
qui nous renvoie à la formation
professionnelle qui nous renvoie à
l'urbanisme qui nous renvoie au logement
donc il ya ceux qui doit revoir la
politique d'immigration on ne peut pas
prendre le problème des banlieues s'il
ya indépendamment de tout cela s'il ya
un problème dans les banlieues c'est la
résultante de dysfonctionnements et de
problèmes dans énormément d'autres
secteurs de la vie sociale de la vie
économique et de la politique on voit
bien que on a besoin d'un projet de
société
et c'est ce projet de société qui
conditionne ce que nous allons la
manière dont nous allons traiter le
problème des banlieues qui est encore
une fois pas seulement problème de
quartier de beaulieu qui est mon général
c'est un problème social aux problèmes
de société vous considérez que c'est un
c'est un échec du président sur ce thème
non c'est pas aimé dit vous même je
crois que le on était très en deçà des
objectifs du plan oui parce que c'est
difficile et on met tout ça une visite
ça fait quand on paye le en paye les
conséquences de 40 ans de dérive c'est
comme pour la finance s'est fait tout ça
se tient d'ailleurs à la finance a
pourrait aussi la société
les dérives de la finance les dés la
mondialisation sans règle les les
dysfonctionnements de loups de l'europe
les la faillite de l'école c'était à
tout ça tout ça pèse très lourd mais
vous pouvez pas en cinq ans
corriger toutes ces dérives elles sont
elles pèsent très lourd il faut faire
évoluer les mentalités pour faire
évoluer les rapports de force il faut
trouver des moyens et vous avez aussi en
regard de sa à éviter que la crise
financière se 30 ans se transforme en
catastrophe ses il faut aussi éviter que
la france devienne la grèce ils ont des
banlieues il y en a des banlieues en
difficultés il y en aura beaucoup plus
et elles seront beaucoup plus en
difficulté encore on s'est trouvés il
faut comprendre qu'on s'est trouvé dans
une situation tout à fait dramatique et
inédite où nous avions déjà à assumer
les conséquences de 40 ans de dérive
d'erreur de petits d'ailleurs sont pas
propres à la france on a les mêmes dans
beaucoup d'autres pays et en plus nous
avons dû affronter la crise donc le
président de la république a fait
beaucoup de réformes il s'est battu sur
beaucoup de fronts il à éviter que la
crise ne se transforme en catastrophe
ça ne nous a pas permis d'obtenir des
résultats satisfaisants dans tous les
domaines c'est vrai mais ici il y avait
plus rien à faire on aurait vous pourrez
peut-être aller se reposer prendre des
vacances et même supprimer les élections
parce que c'est parce que parce que
l'histoire serait terminée
l'état devrait tenir durant sa campagne
est ce qu'il devrait aller jusqu'à ce
cas précis cela colle pas si c'est par
là que la ceni mais là c'était empreinte
de bien comparer des choses qui ont été
plus ou moins bien fait il va lui-même
mais ça c'est sympa ça c'est pas un
problème de mea culpa ci se présente
demain c'est parce que il aura la
conviction que le travail n'est pas
achevé et qui reste énormément de choses
à faire et qui en douteraient d'ailleurs
qui peut se satisfaire de l'état actuel
de la société française dernière session
sur une des futures rivales du président
c'est marine le pen patrick buisson
pense qu'elle fait une mauvaise campagne
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle fait une
mauvaise campagne et est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle est une menace pour le
président au premier tour non mais moi
c'est ce sont des sujets qui
m'intéressent pas non mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce que nous avons à
dire aux français ce que nous avons fait
pose que nous avons à leur dire
c'est donc le point de savoir si nous
fait dans vous fera une bonne campagne
ou mauvaises et si on fait d'ailleurs
une bonne campagne je pense la question
de madame le pen ne se posera pas et
faire une bonne campagne
s'est trouvé les mots qu'il faut et
offrir une espérance à ceux qui n'en
n'ont plus voilà si on offre une
espérance ceux qui n'en n'ont plus ils
iront pas voté pour madame le pen pour
monsieur mélenchon pour je ne sais qui
et si en revanche on n'arrive pas leur
donner une espérance alors qu'ils vont
se réfugier dans sécurisation de donner
une espérance après cinq ans de pouvoir
oui c'est plus difficile parce que 50 25
ans vous vous êtes usé par les
événements c'est il ya une forme de
corrosion et maintenant surtout quand
les événements sont aussi dramatique ce
qu'on a vécu wee cc on a affronté des
difficultés terribles le président a
affronté des situations inédites et
extrêmement grave alors oui ça donne
d'une part une crédibilité mais
forcément ça use il faut convaincre les
français que malgré toutes ces
difficultés on peut encore ouvrir une
espérance pour 20 tours pour demain et
c'est là que vous intervenez henri
guaino comme en 2007 sans doute avec la
force de votre plume vous allez pouvoir
vous en parlait dans un instant je n'ai
pas la prétention de penser que la plume
suffit bien sûr en soit ça crée parfois
des élans et ça soulève les foules on
l'a déjà vu merci perrine devraient nous
rejoindre
et on va parler donc de vous un reagan
au vous aujourd'hui vous demain quel
avenir pour parler de vous et bien non
on est allé voir votre homologue chez
françois hollande figurez vous il n'a
peut-être pas le même rôle exclusif que
vous auprès du candidat socialiste c'est
acquis lino morel rencontrées par aïda
car wash écouter
henri guaino est un personnage singulier
de l'univers politique avec lino morel
son homologue socialiste pour lionel
jospin est maintenant au service de
françois hollande on est persuadé qu'un
gaulliste convaincu
qu'ils talentueux qui beaucoup de deux
je dirais de fond et qui est pas mon
avis une plus qu'une plume au sens où on
peut l'entendre parfois c'est quelqu'un
qui a une vraie pensée et qui a un vrai
fond il ya des plumes qui sont de vrais
écrivains je vous rappelle que régis
debray ou erik orsenna qui est venue
quand même le prix goncourt sont de
grands stylistes de grands écrivains ils
ont été des plume de françois mitterrand
il ya des plans qui sont des gens plus
politique
laurent fabius à l'ajout paix était la
plume de la charte pendant des années
donc que henri guaino est quelqu'un qui
comme je voulais dit un homme qui dès le
départ avait une dimension politique
personnelle très forte une dimension
politique qui lui a permis d'aider
nicolas sarkozy lors de son discours
d'investiture en 2007 à dépasser le
clivage gauche-droite france et celle de
travailleurs qui ont cru à la gauche des
blues je pense que malheureusement la
suite delà de la politique mise en
oeuvre par nicolas sarkozy parle
gouvernement a été évidemment différente
de ceux là et depuis quelques mois le
petit malraux de nicolas sarkozy qu'à
mes envies guaino aime se définir
s'échappe de l'elysée pour ce à quoi on
assiste en ce moment c'est à dire le
fait qui le bat les estrades somme toute
c'est logique il va jusqu'au bout de sa
démarche personnelle qui est une
démarche de départ pour les textes
aujourd'hui henri guaino défend les
choix de son camp devant les militants
et attaque françois hollande une façon
de se trouver une légitimité d'un
politique ce député ou ministre
s'offre un très bon ministre je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il donne envie ça me
paraît une ambition légitime mais il
faudrait encore que la droite
l'emportent
députés ou ministres sans avenir que
vous pouvez que vous pourriez envisager
plutôt j'ai beaucoup d'avenir nous
verrons normes et en grèce mais un
avenir qu'il vous plairait je n'en sais
rien je me poserai la question de mon
avenir après les élections
présidentielles voilà enfin de n'en rien
avant je vous assure même celui de santé
par exemple c'est un navire qui se
construit dès aujourd'hui non
06 il enfin que je faisais campagne pour
être député je ferai campagne dans une
circonscription vous faites quand il ya
des militants ump siens oui ma faille
vote et ses députés ça se passe dans une
circonscription sûre ça sert à rien de
courir dans toute la france d'ailleurs
la plupart ne court pas dans toute la
france il faut travailler une
circonscription le fait si vous êtes
candidat dans
midi de la france et ça ne vous sert à
rien d'aller faire des meetings en ligne
mais quand on est conseiller spécial de
l'elysée donc au service d'une
institution n'a le droit de faire
campagne et tout le monde a le droit
aussi non nous on a quand même une
certaine résignation la misère quand
l'avez jamais vous appliquez votre
obligation de réserve certaine de vous
de vos confrères sont un peu moins sur
la réserve et ils font campagne tous les
jours sur les plateaux de télé notamment
voilà c'est comme ça que vous voyez les
choses ont beaucoup et j'en vois
beaucoup et
il ya deux choses il ya mes fonctions
institutionnelles celle là elles sont au
service de tous les français ce sont son
service de la république et puis il ya
mes engagements personnels ont cessé
pendant cinq ans j'ai travaillé aux
côtés du président de la république je
trouve donc normal de participer à ce
combat politique de prendre ma part de
ce combat et c'est ce que je fais je le
je le fais sans préjudice de mon travail
de ces spéciales c'est donc
contrairement à ce que disait avec lino
morel convient d'écouter finalement ce
que vous nicolas sarkozy disait de vos
mots à vous dans sa bouche en dix ans
en 2007 de ses engagements il les a
tenus il n'y a pas eu un renoncement par
rapport à ces engrais ni aucun
renoncement je pense que c'était forces
et par tous les moyens et avec toute son
énergie de les tenir mais il les amène
une tenue à travers des circonstances
dans des circonstances qui ne sont pas
évidemment celle que nous pouvions
imaginer ni vous ni moi d'ailleurs en
2007 mais aussi un moment vous ne vous
êtes senti trahi par ses engagements la
meilleure - vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de votre rôle institutionnel
dont conserver de liz était français et
de votre militantisme
donc
les choses les deux ne se recoupent pas
forcément il ya peut-être des moments
dans le quinquennat vous avez été moins
enthousiaste que d'autres il ya toujours
des moments où vous trouvez qu'on l'a vu
tout à l'heure où quelle séquence
allemande c'est ce serait mieux si on
faisait autrement bon il ya toujours des
moments la question de ses intentions
tout en question c'est est-ce que je me
suis sentie trahie est-ce que j'ai eu un
problème de conscience à un moment donné
non je n'ai pas eu de problème de
conscience et si j'en avais eu un jeu en
auraient tiré immédiatement les
conséquences parce que ça c'est ma
liberté
je serais parti voilà c'est tout simple
oui tout à fait je suis censé gérer vous
revenez du quinquennat est ce que vous
avez quand même des regrets sur
certaines choses j'ai des regrets je
n'aurais pas été fait il ya beaucoup de
choses qui n'ont pas été faites mais
mais qui passage ne pouvait pas l'être
non je pense qu'on aurait pu faire
encore beaucoup plus sur l'école puisque
on en a parlé tout à l'heure mais que
les circonstances étaient compliqués je
pense qu'on aurait peut-être pu faire la
tva sociale plutôt mis là encore il
fallait que ça soit acceptable s'il
fallait que ça soit possible et on
parlait de mea culpa est ce qu'il ya eu
des erreurs des maladresses commises par
lé présent la république
écoutez moi je ne veux pas
livrés à ce jugement
jugement personnel je pense que le
président de la république a pendant
tout le quinquennat a pris
des exilés exigences terribles de cette
fonction et que le quinquennat a
commencé à un moment où ils étaient
rendus vulnérables par ces problèmes
personne par des vies et des souffrances
personnelles comme nous aurions été bon
chacun d'entre nous il aurait été dans
des circonstances pareilles et que sans
doute il a découvert à l'épreuve de la
fonction que le président de la
république n'avait pas le droit de
laisser transparaître ses sentiments ses
joies ses peines et ses souffrances et
que ce que lui demandait les français au
fond c'est de ne prendre en chasse et de
prendre en charge de leur peine leur
joie lorsque concerne difficultés et lui
n'avaient pas le droit de leur faire
partager les sièges voilà c'est ça c'est
un fait un effort surhumain qu'il a
accompli pendant tout son mandat
je vous avez vu ce changement oui je le
disais j'ai dit enfin moi c'était sûr
c'est quelque chose de difficile c'est
une fonction au fond très humaine elle
exige tellement vous avez appris qu est
ce que vous retenez de ses cinq ans à
l'elysée aux côtés d'un président qui
s'est donc s'est façonné du fil en
aiguille
mais encore une fois je n'en retient
l'idée que la fonction présidentielle
que je connaissais mais de quand même de
plus loin et une terrible exigences
voilà pour celui qui douala qui lui
petit le petit occupe cette fonction a
fortiori dans les circonstances à la
fois personnel et puis économique
mondiale dans lesquels on a
ce quinquennat s'est déroulé et
c'est vraiment très très dur mais j'en
retiens quand même l'idée
forte c'est que faut pas désacralisé
cette fonction
c'est la vieille théorie des deux corps
du roi dans
l'incarnation de l'état de la nation et
au delà de l'humain voilà et elle doit
le rester aussi difficile que ce soit
pour son titulaire le français est un
vieux pays monarchique mais aussi une
volonté au début du quinquennat de la
part de nicolas sarkozy et d'endosser je
dirais l'ensemble un peu des
institutions de la vème république
est-ce que vous pensez que s'il est
réélu si un second quinquennat il y aura
un autre partage entre matignon et
l'elysée
sur une autre marche d'abord aux avait
remarqué que les choses ont évolué au
cours du duc un certain équilibre c'est
le rééquilibrage et réopéré et il est
beau c'est fait c'est fait partie des
plus heureux enfin quinquennat quand
même plus finale sont non chaque sac
instant et mais passionnant et puis on
apprend même temps que les autres mais
toute la fonction le rapport entre le
président a répété le premier ministre
est un problème de la vème république
qui a toujours existé et trouve l
équilibre en fonction des personnalités
aussi a toujours été un pas toujours été
un problème ça a été un problème entre
le général de gaulle michel debré entre
général de gaulle georges pompidou entre
georges pompidou et chaban delmas
souvenez-vous de la difficulté ou entre
vigiles à lescar d'estaing et jacques
chirac premier ministre ça a été un
problème entre françois mitterrand et
non seulement c'est un peu comme un
laboratoire c'est quand même un peu une
erreur d' arrogance non mais je crois
qu'il faut pas donner à ce mot d'abord
c'est pas une déclaration officielle
mais en admettant qu'il dédie ce dont je
me souviens absolument pas mais en
admettant qu'il ait dit le général de
gaulle
savait quand il a nommé georges pompidou
qui était son directeur de cabinet à
matignon avait exactement la même
conception qui n'était pas indigne
tenzin c'était juste que le général de
gaulle disait à disais à mon à
perrefitte écouter peyrefitte arrêté de
me dire que le premier ministre le chef
de la majorité le chef de la majorité
c'est moi qui a dit je veux être un
président qui gouverne georges pompidou
voyez c'est une vieille histoire c'est
vous très vieille histoire ne donnons
pas aux mots un sens caricatural et
péjoine les moeurs du gaullisme avec
elle vous êtes attaché henri guaino fin
de la cinquième place le fasse vraiment
le choix je trouve que l'équilibré c'est
plutôt bien trouvé finalement et pour
finir on parle toujours du président
omniprésent
omnipotent je n'ai jamais vu le
président a ensuite prendre une décision
sans le faire avec les ministres
concernés le premier parce que j'avais
trouvé en nicolas sarkozy un père
politique moi je ne cherche pas à faire
je ne cherche plus les moteurs dans
l'existence est ce que j'ai rencontré
des gens qui ont beaucoup compté pour
moi je pense à philippe séguin de plus
amples mais je ne cherche pas un père je
suis pas à la recherche d'un terne est
ce que vous écrivez en ce moment pour
nicolas sarkozy j'écris tout le temps
pour nicolas sarkozy son livre non mais
je ne répondrai pas ce genre de cas
alors vous nous mettez sur la voie et la
flore
j'écris c'est une de mes c'est une de
mes attributions d'écrire donc il
m'arrive assez souvent d'écrire voilà
pour le reste ça concerne mes relations
d'accord autant la république et je n'ai
pas les mettre sur la place publique ce
merci à vos organes au d'abord être avec
nous aujourd'hui merci père et nous sort
une tous la semaine prochaine ces genres
larcher et l'ancien président du sénat
qui sera l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir